is the James Dolan whisper himself
Michael Kay how are you Michael boy I
never thought I'd be referred to as that
but now that I have named him I'm great
a man you're the only guy I'll talk to
he won't talk to anybody else he'll talk
at people but he'll talk to you Michael
it's it's odd because you know obviously
people are gonna hear what they want to
hear but I I don't think we give him a
soft landing we pretty much asked him
every hard question and I don't think he
does himself any favors no I look being
the go-to guy for somebody and obviously
you just gave voice in this business you
feel a little uneasy it's like why why
will he only speak to me does he feel
like I'm gonna be soft on him I watched
off 45 minutes that you had him on your
show Michael you don't give him a pass
at all so I and to that effect is he is
he reading notes while talking to you it
looks like he's constantly looking down
Michael while he's talked to the Oakley
thing and had a loose-leaf then and on a
lot of people saw a screenshot on yes
where it said notes for interview yeah
and yesterday he just brought like a
legal pad with all these like scribbling
you know hieroglyphics on it and he kept
referring to it and again that doesn't
do him any favors either because you
know he's talking about his team and
he's reading names off now when they
picked Mitchell Robinson in the draft so
it was it was awkward to say the least
yeah that was my if I can if I can have
a favorite part where you asked him his
concern level over his behavior
preventing free agents from coming
especially this summer I mean the
porzingis trade they are all in on July
1st 2019 right now and unfortunately for
the Knicks many other franchises across
the NBA are as well for the same people
and his response was we don't tamper but
this is New York so people tell us that
they're coming he's confident that
players are coming especially since they
have this whole roster full of young
people Laurent budding stars mind you
but they're being groomed for role
playing for these future people who he's
not tampering with and then he proceeds
to look at a piece of
because he needs help to know who's on
his own roster that one was my and that
was just like 45 seconds of insanity it
was it was strange because if you've
been around the Knicks a lot there - had
guys Mills and Perry have been trying to
temper enthusiasm about getting those to
max free agent because you know to me
the porzingis deals a failure you can't
bring in just anybody it's got to be a
Kevin Durant and somebody else has got
to be a difference maker and it's just
from hearing don't say that he is quite
certain not only do you say they're
gonna get the to max Lots but they're
gonna make the plows next year and
they're gonna go deep there's a team
that I believe is 13 and 53 and about as
bad a team as you will ever see and he's
predicting they're gonna go deep in the
playoffs so I hope he's right I mean for
Knick fans sake because in the last 18
years they are statistically literally
the worst team in basketball by a lot
nobody's even close well before we move
on to the football aspect of it of
what's going on in New York City right
now with one major star shipped out one
major star coming in all in the same day
of this interview that you conducted
Michael Kay here on the Rich Eisen show
what what is James Dolan's malfunction
and I know that that's obviously a
negatively infused question but I've
heard from people who know him sees a
generous guy or he can be a generous guy
and he has been around from the New York
community but to come in and give you
video of how he was ambushed by somebody
set up for TMZ and I think one of your
cohorts even pointed out while you
walked into the you you took the bait
to not take responsibility it seems over
and over again you've met him you've
interviewed him what what is wired with
him Michael you know I've had lunch with
him a couple of times you know the
garden sets up lunch you know because I
have a radio show in New York and
whatever and and there's a part of him
and those that have worked for him would
probably blanch at me saying this really
charming you know asked about the kids
it's not he's funny and stuff like that
I told them a couple times why don't you
act like this in public and he always
says I don't care what people think
about me but he does care and he said
that yesterday too I don't
err he cares greatly that's why he's
banned the daily news from from
conference calls and things like that
listen I'm not gonna play dime store
psychologist rich I just think he's a
rich guy who doesn't like to be told
what to do doesn't like to be criticized
he has very thin skin and coming from a
guy whose skin is translucent
I know thin skin this is a guy who does
not like to be told you're wrong and he
probably hasn't been told he's wrong a
lot in his life so I think when a guy
says sell the team it infuriates him he
can't walk away a guy writes him a
letter says he doesn't like what he's
doing he writes back and is nasty to him
again what why that personality trait is
there maybe it's just somebody who was
who's been you know born rich and
expects people to you know acquiesce to
us his every move and people just don't
want you when you own the Knicks or the
Rangers or the Jets or the Giants of the
Yankees or the Mets
you're going to be held accountable that
was another thing that jumped out there
I don't know if this made you kind of
sit up as well when I kind of gave them
an out to say you know this is a public
trust no it's not I own it you know that
I own it and I in a way as it was
transpiring I wasn't trying to save him
but I thought I felt badly for him
because the more he talked I think the
more he made it look bad I mean banning
the guy rich he can't see a Billy Joel
concert anymore at the garden he's
banned from that Michael Buble out it's
not just the Knicks can never walk in
the building he can't go to the Big East
today it's all the team I mean it's
extreme it is it's not only just extreme
it's not New York Michael it's not New
York
I mean people scream things at each
other walking down the streets in New
York City you know and obviously that
you could say that about many American
cities certainly in the Northeast but in
New York City these are this is the you
know this is frequently the the method
of communication certainly if you are
somebody that comes across as
highfalutin and it is a New York
institution the New York Knicks in all
those places that definitely made me sit
up straight and get more outraged and
also him saying essentially Bill Simmons
had an agenda for talking about him
wanting to sell the team because you
know
he might be tight with the Celtics I
mean that was also outrageous and also
passing a law if any any responsibility
about the the welcome mat for the Knicks
or whether anybody wants to step on it
you know so I ask you this is he really
thinking of selling the team or not how
real is that I mean I dropped the
ridiculous six billion dollar offer to
him you know some hedge fund guy they
said he's not eat I mean if he sells the
team now he's gonna look bad but
remember Dave gentlemen said I didn't
sign a channel to trade them and ends up
trading him so I don't know if you could
really believe public figures and one
final thing on the Dolan situation rich
I the discourse in this country in
sports and in politics has become so
uncivil and I told this to dawn when
he's on the show don't sit don't sit in
the stands you're gonna hear it I mean
he doesn't have access to luxury boxes
just you know put yourself up in a
luxury box and you don't the deal with
this but anyhow he said well I on the
team and I like that seat okay then
people gonna yell stuff at you and you
will walk to the stands yeah get used to
it gonna happen in this in this country
now we have no editing valve well I
gotta tell you though I mean Steve
Ballmer and GE bus both sit in the
stands here in staples when the Clippers
and Lakers play and obviously things
aren't going well for the Lakers but
Lakers fans feel like that they're
they're connected to the team and the
bus family connected to the city and
there's no problems like that here in
Los Angeles you might say it's a little
bit more of a laid-back society but with
what's happening with the Lakers right
now the Louis Lakers fans are freaking
out
despite the Chicago last night but the
Lakers though have Championships to fall
back on at least you know you don't have
to be Methuselah to remember them
elastic championship was 1973 and 18
years of just hard basketball he's going
to hear it if he sits in the stands
again if he chooses to sit in the stands
and have people yell that's that's great
but if you're gonna snap on somebody's
did sell the team that he somehow
interpreted as quit I just think I
thought it was such an overreaction I
thought that you know what he agreed to
come in because we started working on it
the previous day I thought that he would
reach out to the guy but they came up
with this
this conspiracy theory you know like the
grassy knoll that the guys like walked
over there they didn't run you saw the
tape yeah they didn't run they walked
over at the same pace as everybody else
and maybe they were trying to get them
but you can only be gotten if you allow
yourself to be gotten any stenny he took
the bait
Michael Kay here on the Rich Eisen show
all right you referred to it well with
Dave gentlemen the general manager of
the New York Giants saying at the
combine we didn't sign Odell long term
to trade him and as a matter of fact he
did trade him to the Cleveland Browns
yesterday for a 1 and a 3 and Jabril
peppers and that's it and that's the
headline of the New York Daily News so I
can understand what the tabloids are
taking it what are the Giants doing do
you think in New York right now I I wish
I could give you a coherent answer none
of it makes sense
letting Landon Collins walk away for
nothing
you've obviously broken down the team
you traded the most talented player this
team has had since Lawrence Taylor and
not only did you not get an unbelievable
return but you took the lesser of their
third-round picks the last pick in the
third round which is essentially a
fourth rounder and you traded a
transcended talent who could be a pain
in the rear I understand it but he's a
great player and I'm not saying that
training him is the wrong thing but the
whole thing that he's been doing the
whole game plan just has a real herding
cats mentality to it what's he doing ok
so if you're breaking this team down to
nothing then you tell me Rich Eisen why
is he lying Manning on the team why are
you carrying a 23 million dollar cap it
on a 38 year old quarterback this team
has no chance to win it's a I read Peter
King called an expansion team would say
Quon Barkley that's essentially what it
is
why is he like Manning there I don't
know I don't have an answer for you
other than the fact that that what
happened with McAdoo and and breaking up
his streak and starting Geno last last
year or two seasons ago now created such
a stir and was such a screw-up that the
Mehra family and with with Tish I think
are just going to let Eli play out the
way he wants on last hold
what happens with the draft I mean they
got two first rounders now if they want
hat they could get with whoever they
want pretty much if they like Mario they
like Haskins they do have the firepower
to go ahead and do it if the Arizona
Cardinals are intent on keeping rosin
and this was a smoke screen
maybe the Giants take it or if they do
love Murray they want a trade rosin
maybe the Giants use that I mean they
have met much flexibility to go ahead
and make some maneuvers to rectify what
you're talking about right now well as
we speak they are you know a lot of the
giant people of the pro day in ocala
Murray hmm
so they're taking a look at him Haskins
supposedly as somebody that they're
interested in I'm just amazed at of the
four or five quarterbacks from last year
and nobody floated their boat because
say Kwan Barclay is outstanding he's a
great running back but they need a
replacement for Eli and I know they
mishandled the Eli benching it was
terrible it was heavy-handed and but
I'll refer to a line that somebody in
the garden organization up my Doland
many years ago how long do I have to pay
Mark Messier for that championship are
you messed up I mean it was terrible
what they did to Eli but to have him on
this roster now just doesn't make any
sport sense it just it's it's illumise
now I just don't get it I don't
understand it I don't I mean they they
they've decimated the defense you get a
little you get rid of Vernon last year
you got rid of snacks
Eli Apple Landon Collins I mean you
should see the spin that's out here in
New York rich when the columns is one of
the worst players of all time according
to people about a leaking miss that that
are close to the job the worst can't
cover anybody so the three Pro Bowls I
guess it's like that College you know
it's like he's paid to get into USC no
he took the test himself in the Pro Bowl
I don't think is it buddy so I guess the
Giants are a lesser house to use this
whole analogy
right because the spin I'm hearing why
you or it's not spin it could be true
here Michael Michael K from the Michael
Kay show yes Network ESPN right here in
the Richards Joe what I'm hearing and
from information men and women who are
close to the situation is the Giants
think they're better off without Oh Dell
they felt like he was required to be
force-fed on the field and obviously the
the Lil Wayne interview with ESPN last
year and and there are multiple things
that we apparently don't know about that
less will be more on this front I could
buy it i I can actually buy it but
here's what I don't understand just like
an understand the Landon Collins thing
so Landon Collins can't play can't cover
anybody
you knew that last year you were one in
seven why don't you trade them you
didn't so you got nothing for him except
for a compensatory pick now Odell
Beckham you essentially last year rich
paid him 21 million dollars to play 12
games all you had to do was pick up his
50 or option you knew what he was it
wasn't a great revelation last year
about what he was he is who he is he's a
great talented player who could be
obtained in the rear to an organization
but his teammates loved him
he supposedly beloved in that room again
why'd you give him all that money why
are you taking me the camp it now all
the money they spent for 12 games of
Odell Beckham jr. it seems like they
keep changing their plan on the fly I
don't
that's what's so first thing about this
I don't understand what they're doing
well yeah maybe they still have some
moves left over the next five weeks
between now and the draft we'll see what
happens Michael Kay here on the Rich
Eisen show let's hit levy on bail you
mentioned how Odell's the most talent
the Giants since Lawrence Taylor you
could say this is the most talented jet
certainly at the position since Curtis
Martin and what he's been able to do now
the Jets have him to help balance out
Sam Darnell coach Crowder is not a
slouch either
pick up the slot receiver and CJ Mosley
they really
paid him to put him right in the middle
of their defense do you think the Jets
have put together a team that can
threaten the New England Patriots in the
AFC East Michael okay a lot of it
depends obviously if Donald takes the
next step the second year step that a
lot of those quarterbacks take I would
have liked if Barr didn't change his
mind giving them somebody if you get to
the quarterback but now with the moves
that they made I like the Meuse they've
made a lot they can use that number
three pick to get an edge rusher and
their draft and they're so good Michael
I saw them at the combine myself I mean
it was one I pop ER after another at the
combine at that pass rush position there
they're deep and certainly if Murray
goes first overall they they can have
their pick not named Bosa essentially I
think I agree I mean they're they're in
a good situation
I think they've gotten better I think
they're obviously they're better than
the Dolphins who look like they're
breaking it down they're better than the
bills I don't think that they caught up
to the Patriots but I think they've
taken great steps they really have I
think they've spent their money wisely
aggressively they didn't get in the the
I think the best bargain they got rich
was Le'Veon Bell who I think overrated
his value in the market and now you
really have to wonder about the wisdom
of him sitting out last year and 14
million dollars we'll never get back and
he's essentially taking the same
contract with the Jets that that the
Steelers offered so I don't understand
it and we'll see if it works out for him
I wonder if he's regretting what he did
but he gets to play in New York City
where he certainly could sell his brand
and he's a great player and he's gonna
play with a potentially outstanding
quarterback so everything they just have
done so far other than lose out on Barr
who won I guess went back on his word I
think they've done a great job in free
agent so I'll finish up with this one
here in Los Angeles just I guess bring
it all full circle there is a
conversation as to whether the Clippers
have passed the Lakers everyone does
I'll you know pay attention the Lakers
far more than the Clippers but the
Clippers are going to the playoffs the
Lakers are going to be wondering what's
happening next have the Jets done to the
Giants what it seems the Clippers are
doing in the Lakers here have they
eclipsed them do you think Michael in
the short-term they certainly have I
never bet against you know the legacy
team like you know for about a decade
they're like the Mets eclipsed the
Yankees but the Yankees are still the
Yankees so the Giants are always going
to be the Giants you know 1925 Giants
drive and you know the for Super Bowl so
I think that they and they're building
to something I would hope but right now
the Jets are definitely the the much
sexier team to root for and they're
gonna have more wins I believe I mean if
Pat Shermer can can go 88 with this team
he should go right to Canton I mean they
should give him that ugly jacket right
away but I don't I don't see a mate on
this team if they get for wear again
there's still stuff they have to do but
they've broken this team down to nothing
while the Jets have built and this was
the this was a big offseason for the
Jets and you know what I think they're
taking great advantage of it they've
done all the right things you
mispronounced the word gold for the
jacket Michael you said said some other
four-letter word I don't understand you
associating lankan century 21 Michael
great job with James Dolan man that was
that was a riveting watch for sure
random pure listen for your listeners as
well and I'd love to have you back on
close to the first pitch of baseball
season anytime right back at you that's
Michael Kay of the Michael Kay show you
got to check out that interview with
Dolan you could check it out I'm sure on
his website a poor or definitely you
tube which is how I saw the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience